[Musique]
dans le débat sur france 24 20e jour de
guerre en ukraine alors que kiev a
annoncé un couvre-feu et que 3 millions
d'ukrainiens ont déjà fui le pays côté
diplomatique le conflit fait en re
surgir le bras de fer entre les états
unis et la chine selon le new york times
pékin aurait passé un accord militaire
et économique avec moscou et la chine
pourraient se livrer à des représailles
si les sanctions s'appliquer à son pays
a affirmé en tout cas son ministre des
affaires étrangères les etats unis ont
jugé profondément préoccupant
l'alignement de la chine avec la russie
après une rencontre à rome hier entre
jake sullivan le conseiller américain à
la sécurité nationale est le plus haut
responsable du parti communiste chinois
la chine refuse de condamner ouvertement
l'opération russe mais elle s'est
félicitée la semaine dernière d'une
amitié avec la russie solide comme un
roc at elle dit alors à quoi joue la
chine finalement dans le conflit
ukrainien xi jingping est il un
véritable allié de vladimir poutine ce
rapprochement entre la chine et la
russie peut-il présager d'un nouvel
ordre mondial on va en parler avec mes
invités j'ai le plaisir d'avoir à mes
côtés marie holzman bonsoir vous êtes
sinologue présidente de l'association
solidarité chine bonsoir et bienvenue à
vous en face de vous jean françois di
meglio bonsoir président de léger à
center bienvenue jean françois di meglio
encore une fois dans ce débat elvire
fabry est à côté de vous bonsoir
chercheuse senio seniors filles imagine
à l'institut jacques delors bonsoir à
vous bienvenue dans le débat et puis
nous avons le général jean vincent
brisset avec nous ce soir bonsoir en
direct par ça il peut donc de
montpellier chercheur associé à l'iris
et spécialiste des questions
stratégiques et de défense en asie avant
de démarrer ces discussions je vous
propose d'écouter le porte-parole du
ministère des affaires étrangères
chinois c'était ce matin c'était à
l'issue de cette rencontre justement à
rome de jake sullivan le conseiller à la
sécurité nationale du président
américain est le plus haut responsable
du parti communiste chinois coté
diplomatie en écoute
romain
nous demandons instamment aux états unis
de ne pas nuire aux intérêts de la chine
par le biais de sa diplomatie à l'égard
de la russie
la chine et la russie continuerons à
mener une coopération économique
commerciale normale dans un esprit de
respect mutuel d'égalité et de bénéfice
jean françois di meglio qu'est ce que ça
veut dire la chine donc met en avant ses
intérêts on l'entend donc un par la voix
de ce porte parole et en même temps il
n'a pas confirmé cet accord économique
et militaire avec moscou tout en disant
qu elle adhéra relations économiques
avec la russie qu'est ce que c'est que à
quoi jouent les filles noires ça veut
dire comme d'habitude la chine dit ce
qu'elle fait elle fait ce qu'elle dit là
elle dit qu'elle pense à ses intérêts en
premier ses intérêts bien sûr on nous
dira que l'europe est le premier client
de la chine mais ses intérêts avant tout
je dirais pour que la machine tourne
c'est déjà ses intérêts sécurité
énergétique ça c'est assez important
avec un approvisionnement avec un
approvisionnement russe et puis les
projets aussi d'approvisionnement russe
qui qui qui vont aller qui vont aller
croissant donc ça c'est déjà son intérêt
et puis son intérêt aussi c'est d'une
façon ou d'une autre de ne pas céder une
alliance trop forte ou de ne pas montrer
d'intérêt trop convergent avec un
occident dont elle dit de plus en plus
et de plus en plus fort qu'il n'est pas
sur la même longueur d'onde qu'elle donc
à une sorte de radicalisation du
discours chinois vos pensées c'est pas
aujourd'hui qu'il apparaît ce discours
plus radical on sait bien qu'il apparaît
depuis 2012 mais même lorsqu'ils
n'étaient pas radical il était déjà sous
jacente donc la surprise je dirais n'est
pas aussi forte qu'on aurait pu
l'imaginer donc et un bloc russie chine
ans alors face à l'occident je pense
qu'effectivement le concept de glock
n'est pas tout à fait présent dans
l'esprit d'un diplomate chinois je
répète le mot d'intérêt le bloc c'est
pas simplement des intérêts c'est
beaucoup plus que ça les intérêts font
qu effectivement la chine va privilégier
ce qui n'est pas no interprétation d'une
chine prête à composer avec nous elvire
fabry y est pourtant on va me dire que
la chine est même très dépendante de
l'occident d'un point de vue économique
et de l'europe en particulier puisque
c'est vrai qu'il ya ses importations de
gaz et de produits agricoles russe mais
il y à une dépendance économique et on
le sait que côté européen eh bien il ya
toujours eu des accords commerciaux avec
la chine donc est ce qu'elle peut et
est-ce que prend un risque justement
face à ces sanctions qu'on lui retire
finalement ses liens commerciaux côté la
dépendance de la chine vis-à-vis de
l'union européenne elle est six fois
plus importante que vis-à-vis de la
russie évidemment on le sait la russie a
des intérêts à moyen long terme pouvoir
mettre la main un peu sur la manne
énergétique et agricole russe et
maintenant ce n'est pas faisable à court
terme en matière d'énergie ça a été
suffisamment commenter toutes ces
dernières semaines on sait très bien que
la russie ne peut pas basculer pour des
raisons d'infrastructures qui n'existe
pas encore toutes ses exportations vers
la chine et la chine dépend aujourd'hui
encore trop non seulement du marché
européen mais du marché américain à la
fois en matière des changes courants que
continue mais surtout sur le plan
technologique est là aujourd'hui c'est
au coeur des sanctions qui sont
appliquées notamment en partie parce
qu'il y ait par les états unis avec
leurs moyens de pression sur
l'extraterritorialité et elle ne peut
pas y renoncer à court terme et tout le
problème c'est de savoir si on a affaire
à un conflit de court terme et de long
terme et ce qui est ce qui est plus vrai
le plus vraisemblable c'est qu'on est on
s'oriente vers un scénario de long terme
donc difficile pour elle de tenir
justement cette position que vient de
soutenir jean françois di meglio s'est
particulièrement difficile à un moment
où l'économie chinoise est en paix et en
décélération les on attend une
croissance pour 2022 qui serait plutôt
autour du 5.5 de croissance qui est un
peu le seuil limite que voulait éviter
la chine et puisque l'on voit surtout
depuis depuis quelques jours c'est la
façon dont les marchés financiers sont
en train de réagir et il ya déjà une
réactivité très forte avec des actions
chinoises qui sont en train de dévisser
complètement non seulement à hong kong à
new york et qui montre que là ça
pourrait être beaucoup plus préoccupant
pour pour l'économie chinoise général
jean vincent brisset d'un point de vue
militaire justement est ce que la chine
a passé un accord militaire avec la
russie on n'a pas vraiment réussi à
savoir puisqu'elle n'a pas confirmé les
informations du new york times et la
russie non plus d'ailleurs
alors le les accords militaires de la
chine avec d'autres pays c'est quelque
chose qui est toujours été très opaque
et la chine n'a pas d'alliés au sens
militaire du terme elle a jamais eu
vraiment d'alliés et avec la russie il
reste des conflits et des contentieux
des contentieux territoriaux qui remonte
à insectes piste elle est traitée ségo
elle estime qu'elle s'efface folie d'un
million de kilomètres carrés de
territoire en extrême orient russe et à
côté de ça la chine dépend certaine
manière sur le plan militaire à la fois
de l'ukraine et ses bureaux d'études qui
le transférait pas mal de technologie et
la russie porter la copie les lasarrois
de matériel et qui continue quand même à
lui fournir à ce que parce que ça
apporte la russie et des moteurs
d'avions des moteurs de bateaux et un
certain nombre d'autres choses donc il
ya une application afin une mélange les
trois parties ukraine russie et chine la
chine elle a surtout peur des sanctions
internationales parce que c'est que
pourrait pas très bien et sports renvoie
justement ces images qui ont tourné
beaucoup sur les réseaux sociaux
aujourd'hui de cette productrice russe
marina au final nicolas qui a brandi une
pancarte anti guerre pendant le journal
télévisé russe sur la chaîne d'état elle
a été arrêtée elle a finalement été
libérés condamnés à une amende
elle reste tout de même encore de la
prison on va regarder justement on va
l'écouter
ce qui se passe actuellement en ukraine
est un crime la russie est un pays
agresseur et la responsabilité incombe à
une seule personne vladimir poutine
mario semaine quand on voit ces images
aussi d'arrestations en russie est ce
qu'on retrouve pas un peu les méthodes
chinoises en russie les méthodes
soviétiques d'un côté ou celle même du
parti communiste en chine sera pas un
petit anneau domaine ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui enfin vous avez raison
d'évoquer tiananmen parce que au fond on
pourrait se dire qu'aujourd'hui chez
jean ping a l'occasion de se rapprocher
de l'occident parce que là maintenant
tout le monde est contre la russie et la
chine aurait pu dire ou du moins faire
semblant de se rapprocher un peu de
l'occident après tiananmen la chine a
été ostracisé terriblement elle n'a
réussi à se sortir de cette espèce de
glacis période glace de glaciation que à
cause du 11 septembre là les états unis
avaient besoin de faire la guerre contre
le terrorisme
la chine a dit bon nous on fait la
guerre avec vous et puis après ça ça
fait re des dégénérés depuis l'arrivée
au pouvoir de chez jean ping la
situation en chine sur le plan des
droits de l'homme des relations avec
l'extérieur n'a fait que se dégrader la
chine n'a plus d'amis elle est en
conflit avec ses voisins proches avec le
vietnam taiwan plus ou moins les
philippines avec le japon elle est quand
même assez mal barré et donc on aurait
pensé que l aurait fait un petit geste
vers l'occident sans trop s'engager mais
au moins un petit quelque chose elle ne
le fait pas elle ne fait pas et ce
qu'est un rapprochement idéologique peut
être à faire justement non jeu en chine
je pense que j'aime bien ce qu'a dit la
journaliste russe elle a dit le coupable
c'est poutine elle n'a pas dit c'est le
gouvernement russe ou le ou la politique
russe ella lycée poutine en chine on
peut dire c'est chez jean ping on est on
a affaire en russie un pouvoir qui
devient de plus en plus totalitaire
en chine on y est on y est depuis un bon
moment donc dans un gouvernement
totalitaire il y en a qu'un qui décide
et la syrie jean ping je pense pas que
son entourage soit tout à fait d'accord
avec lui mais ça on nous on saura jamais
jean françois di meglio est ce que ça
ira proches pas quelque part escape à
une sorte de guerre anti démocratique
pour effet livrer ensemble que peut-être
justement ce blog on passait peut-être
plus un bloc idéologique avec xi
jingping et vladimir poutine ont entre
démocratie il peut il est possible il
est possible qu effectivement
objectivement ça les rapproche en
particulier quand on regarde notre point
de vue à nous il est clair que ça les
rapproche vu de paris ce qui fonctionne
à mon avis c'est beaucoup plus des
volontés effectivement des volonté de
puissance et une volonté de puissance
qui n'a rien à voir si vous me permettez
avec les analyses que nous nous pouvons
faire ça fait quand même quinze jours ou
trois semaines ou même un peu plus qu on
nous a expliqué que et on était
probablement autour de cette table tous
du même avis non il était pas rationnel
que la russie attaque l'ukraine dont la
russie attaque et l'ukraine il n'est
absolument pas rationnel que qu'un
gouvernement occidental ci était la
place de sitting pays prennent le parti
de poutine ou en tout cas s'en rapproche
rien ne nous dit que tout se passera
comme dans la tête d'un occidental on
est dans une logique très différentes et
il faut qu'on se mette dans la tête que
cette logique n'est pas la nôtre 6 kg
jordan et là vous êtes un spécialiste et
quelle logique en fait qu'elle veut nous
nous faire réaliser cette chine par
exemple un exemple avec taïwan et la
chine regarde par exemple est-ce que
l'ukraine pour la russie serait en fait
la taiwan pour la chine va mal elle
parce que les médias en parlent oui
alors ce matin là dans ce temps elle
saute aux yeux
si vous me permettez c'est un peu plus
compliqué que ça bien que je dis ce que
je dis et je pense qu'à pas besoin
d'être spécialiste pour ça c'est qu'il
ya une volonté de puissance il ya une
volonté d'affirmation qui est très
claire la question de taiwan elle et
elle va être réglé d'une façon
extrêmement pragmatiques comme tout ce
que fait la chine c'est à dire en voyant
quelles sont les difficultés que la
russie peut rencontrer dans sa conquête
de l'ukraine et en pesant y compris avec
des militaires c'est comme chez nous je
dirais ya en permanence des scénarios de
guerre qui tourne et ses scénarios de
guerre sont en permanence alimenter
parce qu'on peut observer sur le terrain
on le scénario du débarquement ou de la
prise de taïwan il a été étudié
décortiquer des dizaines de fois mais
peut y être modifié en fonction
justement ce qui se passe à ce lien
absolument je pense qu'effectivement il
ya à la fois une opportunité historique
pour des choses du point de vue chinois
et puis une autre opportunité historique
pour étudier en laboratoire ce qui peut
se passer lorsqu'une telle opération est
lancée général jean vincent brisset vous
êtes d'accord s4 taiwan la thaïlande la
presse est ce que fait pas justement ce
rapprochement entre l'ukraine et
taiwan avec justement ces zones
d'affluence qui que la russie aurait
justement avec l'ukraine et que la chine
soit à avoir avec taïwan vous êtes
d'accord à ce que l'irlande hier jean
françois di meglio oui mais je suis
alors je suis très largement d'accord
mais j'ai été étonné parce qu'avant le à
voir l'entrée de la russie en ukraine on
a beaucoup parlé des craintes symétrique
préfère la chine vis-à-vis de taiwan et
mais les correspondants que je peux
avoir à taiwan en particulier un ami
commun avec europhobie meglio qui me dis
que finalement il n'y a pas tellement
dans voir ceux du côté taïwan alors que
effet les différences de puissance au
pays 20 millions d'habitants est un pays
d'un milliard 400 millions sont
tellement énormes on pourrait imaginer
que
pour un valet taiwan en quelques heures
mais il pourrait tirer les leçons tout
de même de ce qui se passe en ukraine
c'est ce que disait jean françois di
meglio
d'autant plus que autant là ya pas eu de
promesse de soutien militaire attend à
l'ukraine si la russie attaquer autant
les états unis en particulier ont parlé
et en particulier le président banda ont
parlé d'un vrai soutien militaire si
quelque chose se passait en direction de
taïwan et la chine a beaucoup plus à
perdre d'une ostracisation au niveau
international que la russie sans doute
justement marie holzman moi j'ai lu dans
fight the times que certains en chine
voit cette guerre comme une erreur
irréversible dont la chine devrait se
dissocier
évidemment je veux dire le monde entier
pense à la le problème des chinois c'est
effectivement ce que disait jean
françois tout à l'heure c'est un
problème de valeurs ça fait moment que
si jean ping nous dit nos valeurs c'est
le rêve chinois c'est le modèle chinois
c'est la façon de gérer la crise du coc
vite par exemple on fait 0 k bon on voit
ce qu'est ce que ça donne ils ont fait
des vaccins qui n'était pas au point
donc maintenant dès que le coc vide
arrive à tout le monde tombe malade et
il continue du façon totalitaire à
enfermer 17 millions de gens en l'espace
de quelques heures le résultat c'est que
la société maintenant n'en peut plus
alors pendant les jeux olympiques il
fallait pas dire qu'il y avait des co
vide du coup quand 1,4 coville était
déclarée on enfermait tout le monde et
on a eu des cas terrible des lycées où
nous tous les lycéens se sont
contaminées mutuellement puisqu'il
n'avait plus droit de sortir du du lycée
donc on est dans une situation absurde
le la position pour moi la position de
chip jichi jean ping maintenant ne
concerne que lui et n'intéresse que lui
oui si vous aimez vous émettez pour
rebondir sur le sur le confinement de
shenzhen puisque c'est ça qu'on parle
bien sûr que l'économie c'est très
important pour les dirigeants chinois et
bien sûr que la chine ne serait pas là
si les chinois n'avaient pas mis
l'accent sur l'économie mais le fait qu
on hésite visiblement pas une seconde
pour fermer quelque chose qui aux yeux
de l'occident et la nouvelle chine la
chine du 21e siècle shenzhen là où
justement la chine a besoin de montrer
qu'elle est à la pointe et elle est
réellement à la pointe on n'hésite pas
parce que précisément ce qui prime c'est
cette obsession du zéro comme il y aura
un moment où ça n'a plus d'importance la
chine a gagné son histoire de 0 qu'ovide
parce que c'est omicron qui débarque
aujourd'hui et omicron on sait tous que
finalement ça n'est pas grave et donc
elle va passer cette phase omis cette
vague omicron et elle aura gagné et elle
ne sortira pas de son zéro que vides
elvire fabry donc pas effectivement
l'économie n'est pas forcément une
priorité par la chine ou je pense qu'il
faut quand même dire agir la question de
l'autosuffisance chinois s'est on sait
que c'est un objectif que la chine s'est
donnée de pouvoir compter de plus en
plus sur la consommation de son marché
interne de pouvoir monter en gamme en
matière d'innovation technologique
maintenant toute la question sexy si
elle se mettait à dos on va dire ce frau
occidental qui s'est constitué et
vis-à-vis de la russie le problème
encore une fois c'est qu'elle se coupent
l'accès à des technologies occidentales
dont elle a besoin également pour
construire cette autosuffisance et
devenir le champion technologiques
auxquelles elle aspire alors l on sait
que le gouvernement chinois est prêt à
faire un peu avant une stratégie d ponge
encaissé un coût économique et aux et au
contraire ça vibre et un peu la fibre
nationaliste chinoise
par son sont l'affirmation de son modèle
mais là en l'occurrence à freinerait
véritablement sa course et technologies
ville elvire hong kong le centre
financier asiatique regardez ce qui se
passe à hong kong aujourd'hui est ce que
la chine a hésité un instant
à faire de hong kong que c'est devenu
aujourd'hui et est ce que vous pensez
qu'il ya un dirigeant chinois qui
sourcils du fait que les forces vives de
hong kong sont en train de partir y
compris dans le golfe pour faire tourner
des boîtes occidental qui était basé en
congrès ce que j'en sais que c'est léger
mais on n'a pas réagi sur le sur le cas
de hong kong là il se trouve que la
réponse qui est qui et à des données sur
d'une autre et d'une autre ampleur
épreuve et encore une fois cette
réaction des marchés financiers quand
même est une pression également alors on
va écouter puisque justement vous parlez
de position de l'occident va écouter
secrétaire général de l'otan qui demande
vous allez le voir aujourd'hui en tout
cas aux chinois de condamné l'invasion
russe
sawtche en rien un shojo in the last of
the world la chine devrait rejoindre le
reste du monde et condamné fermement
l'invasion brutale de la russie en
ukraine
[Musique]
tout soutien la russie militaires ou non
l'aide à poursuivre une guerre brutale
contre l'ukraine qui est un pays
indépendant et souverain et l'aide à
poursuivre une guerre entraînant la mort
la souffrance et la destruction
se flinguent général jean vincent
brisset on voit bien que la pression
monte tout de même sur la chine a on
entend le secrétaire général de l'otan
qui demande à la chine cette fois de
prendre position de condamner la vision
russe la chine peut-elle céder aux
pressions des américains et de l'otan
ça me paraît difficile même si on a
constaté que la chine avait cédé quant
aux un peu président trump a voulu
casser les reins de la corée du nord la
chine qui avait toujours soutenu plutôt
la corée du nord a abandonné soutien et
a permis un certain nombre de choses
donc on peut toujours penser que la
chine pourrait changer
mais dans l'esprit de sting ping ça
m'étonnerait parce que all you from là
on lui jette pas russie dans les bras et
il se trouve dans la possibilité de
recréer un groupe
pas une alliance bien entendu mais un
groupe au moins pour le moyen terme dans
lequel la chine sera position forte et
la russie en position de membre s et ça
c'est un petit peu un rêve pour le
gouvernement chinois la pression donc
marié holzman est insuffisante du côté
des occidentaux ça ne fonctionnera pas
je pense que ça ne fonctionnera pas il
ya aussi une raison c'est que je parlais
tout à l'heure de la chine boucs
émissaires des pays occidentaux
démocratiques etc pendant longtemps
quelque part maintenant ils sont
contents que ce soit la russie donc
maintenant l'attention est tournée sur
la russie c'est eux qui sont les plus
méchants et le fait que ce soit eux qui
soit visée ça leur donne un petit peu de
répit ils peuvent s'organiser comme il
veut et ça les arrange si la russie
s'effondrait je pense que tôt ou tard la
chine communiste s'effondre est aussi
donc pour le moment ils ont une adresse
que la relance n'ont pas intérêt jean
françois di meglio ils n'ont pas intérêt
tout même que les chinois
que là où il ya déjà une session
chinoise qui l'effondrement de l'urss
l'effondrement de l'urss et est une
obsession dans l'esprit de direction
catastrophe de l'histoire comme 10 à
blagnac faut-il pousser jean ping voilà
vraiment là et donc effectivement la
répétition de cet événement avec des
conséquences que nous occidentaux nous
imaginons dans nos rêves effectivement
parce que un effondrement du régime
poutine voudrait dire ce que nous
n'avons pas réussi à faire dans les
années 90 et ce basculement de la russie
vers l'europe de l'ouest ce qui après
tout serait pas si choquant quand on
aime la russie quand on connaît bien
réussi mais effectivement pour ce serait
une catastrophe pour situer ces
pressions justement du côté de
l'occident est ce qu'elles vont pousser
la chine tout de même à être plus clair
mais je crois que la chine est claire je
crois qu'il ignore encore une fois donc
on va demander beaucoup de choses de la
film et vous savez mais elles exigent
maison pardonne mais non mais elle
savait
bien de voter lorsque vous attendez un
nom d'un interlocuteur chinois elle
parle d'elle pouvait l'attendre très
longtemps la chine s'est abstenue
systématiquement sur toutes les
questions ukrainienne elle a utilisé son
veto pour les question syrienne pour
l'ukraine elle n'a jamais utilisé son
veto et un s'est abstenu l'élément le
plus étonnant dans le vote à l'onu c'est
et l'inde ça a été l'abstention de
l'inde mais l'abstention de la chine
n'est pas un élément moteur oui donc ça
veut dire est ce qu'elle est un allié
fiable de vladimir poutine
aussi fiable que sont ces intérêts
encore une fois c'est à dire que
effectivement elles veulent soutenir je
pense que et
poutine ne peut pas ne pas être
conscient çà et là effectivement besoin
la russie la russie bien sûr besoin de
l'aja va continuer à lui faire l'avancé
selon l'excellent je pense et je pense
on est en train de construire des
scénarios il faut être très prudent en
construisant ses scénarios je pense
qu'elle va le soutenir pour autant que
ça lui profite c'est à dire qu'à un
moment où les actifs russes comme ils
sont en train de 2,2 de le faire vont
être à des prix tout à fait abordable
pour la chine ce sera une occasion
extraordinaire si du jour au lendemain
ces actifs étaient évalués
et bien effectivement ce serait ce
serait encore mieux pour l'acide on a
parlé de l'ukraine tout à l'heure
l'argument qui consiste à dire la chine
a des intérêts en ukraine permettez moi
aussi de le contester c'est probablement
mon jour parce que si jamais l'ukraine
tombe aux mains de la russie est ce que
pour autant la chine qui auraient
soutenu la russie serait mal en point et
20 ans elle aurait effectivement les
technologies qui sautent en ukraine où
est le problème elvire fabry
je pense qu'il faut distinguer une
évolution de la position chinoise qui va
vraisemblablement
cultiver si je puis dire sa neutralité
son nom son ambiguïté ne trouve au récit
ou réciproquement de ce qu'elle pourra
faire sous le manteau en essayant de
contourner le plus possible les
sanctions notamment les sanctions
américaines enfin tout ce que le tout ce
que les états unis peuvent actionner est
là toute la question c'est que on sait
que
la russie a déjà demandé à pékin de
l'approvisionner en pièces intermédiaire
pour des composants prendre pour de
l'armement est levée
c'est tout là là ça devient plus
compliqué c'est si elle trouve les
moyens de le faire de manière discrète
elle le fera tant que possible mais mais
c'est pour ça qu actuellement depuis il
dort pas comme le feraient appel de
manière discrète pour justement échappée
irait à au durcissement occidentale
louis on sait que là les sanctions
américaines ce qu'il faut avoir en tête
c'est que c'est pas simplement les des
restrictions sur les exportation de
technologie américaine vis-à-vis de la
russie c'est la section d'exportation
d'exportation de qui comprennent tout
composante technologique américain donc
ça peut être également même des semi
conducteurs chinois dans la russie a
terriblement besoin mais qui comprennent
des composants américains ils se font
pas ce qu'ils les doigts c'est la règle
aitor à laquelle tout le monde de tout
le monde est soumis lors ce qui
effectivement on exporte du matériel
normes et américains pour un pays sous
embargo
on a en a effectivement en a
effectivement ce problème donc a subi
ces sanctions la chine aussi
elle subit elle promet je pense qu'elle
exposerait du nord je pense que le panel
de ses corée du nord corée du nord il ya
des sanctions la chine n'a jamais rejeté
les sanctions donc en principe elle
applique les sanctions qui peut dire
qu'aujourd'hui la chine n'a pas plus ou
moins soutenu le régime de corée du nord
au delà des sanctions qui sont imposés
personne ce que voulait dire général
jean vincent brisset c'est intéressant
de voir tous nos psys jean ping et
l'ailleurs poutine se sont vus en marge
des jo c'était un petit moment les
chinois me semble-t-il avait soutenu
l'idée que l'ukraine ne rejoigne jamais
l'otan or zelensky aujourd'hui volodymyr
zelensky le président ukrainien a
affirmé qu'il fallait reconnaître que
l'ukraine ne pourra pas intégrer l'otan
que l'ukraine alors ça veut probablement
dire que l'ukraine est en train de
renoncer à entrer dans l'otan donc
j'imagine que ça ne peut que satisfaire
la russie et la chine
cela rend enfin l'otan c'est quelque
chose d'abominable pour la chine comme
le fût ce le partenariat avec
l'australie la nouvelle zélande ça c'est
extrêmement clair la chine aime bien
négocié en tête à tête pays contre pays
la chine face à une coalition de pays
comme elles comme cela a été le cas de
la barre à meaux après qu'elle mène
c'est quelque chose qui me terrifie les
dirigeants chinois donc si l'ukraine ne
rentre pas dans le temps c'est quelque
chose qui pourrait apparaître comme
affaiblir l'otan est donc plutôt plaire
aux chinois he et
limiter la potentialité
des attaques contre la chine est ce que
la chine est tout de même embarrassé ou
pas jusqu'où est ce qu elle peut
soutenir la russie
ça c'est difficile à dire mais ce qui
est clair en tout cas c'est que la chine
a une tradition multimillénaire de la
tactique donc ils savent ils savent
avancer à petits pas ils savent se
cacher il ça prend des décisions qui les
intéresse quand ça les intéresse et
comme disait jean françois tout à
l'heure ils vont soutenir la russie tant
que ça leur rapporte quelque chose
c'est un allié quand même assez volatile
au moment où ils auront d'autres
intérêts ils iront ailleurs mais je
crois qu'il faut garder en tête que la
chine est devenue l'ennemie des valeurs
occidentales
elle veut tout sauf tomber dans la
démocratie si on peut dire mais j'ai
aussi l'impression que si jean ping
depuis quelques années n'a fait que des
mauvaises erreur encore une fois je cite
jean françois écrasé hong kong c'est une
c'est d'une bêtise abyssale tous les
grands dirigeants avaient mis leurs
économies a hong kong les banques de
hong kong sont fiables elles sont
transparentes enfin elle fonctionne bien
maintenant les gens qui entourent si
jean ping pour la plupart doivent le mot
dire vraiment très énergiquement sa
stratégie du zéro co vide à mon avis
était une erreur il a empêché la société
de vivre il l'a maltraité et il la
torture est enfin on peut dire vraiment
torturé en enfermant les gens pendant
des mois sa politique interne mais à
l'égard de moscou tout de même bienvenu
sur une grande rivalité entre ces deux
pays oui c'étaient des amis ennemis des
ennemis à miss a toujours été comme ça
et donc justement qu'est ce que ça veut
dire ça amis ennemis dans ses three days
l'abbé jean kiffer a dit moi ça ne
fonctionne pas ça ne fonctionne pas
comme le faisait le campisme pour
reprendre l'expression de bertrand badie
on n'est plus dans une logique de quand
on est dans une logique d'opportunité
est effectivement dans cette tactique
chinoise les opportunités prévalent sur
l'appartenance un camp donc aujourd'hui
c'est ça et peut-être que l'arbitrage
coup opportunité est plutôt en faveur
des opportunités rapprochant aujourd'hui
des dirigeants chinois des dirigeants
russes donc opportunisme plutôt que oui
oui tout à fait opportunisme dans le
cadre d'une ambition qui est elle claire
et pas du tout pour tunis qui était
dogmatique
peut-être qu'il faut aussi introduire
dans le débat
les pays tiers dont on parle pas et
notamment tous les pays du sud est
asiatique qui sont deux ans maintenant
qu'ils sont de plus en plus intégrés à
la chine mais qui se méfie aussi
beaucoup de l'émergence de la chine qui
sont restés neutres dans ce débat
considérant que c'est une guerre
éloignés et non ils n'ont pas pris
position et là aussi la réaction de la
chine aurait un impact sur tous ses
partenaires dont a besoin la chine et
parce que encore une fois elle pousse
son intégration l'asian est devenue le
premier partenaire commercial de la
chine et c'est vrai également pour
l'amérique latine pour l'afrique toutes
les lanes accord d'ailleurs me
semble-t-il aussi avec l'australie et le
japon du côté chinois air cep qui a été
mis en paiement en valeur le 1er janvier
2022 donc quinze pays les dix pays de la
zone plus la corée la chine et japon
plus le centre de l'accident taux entre
guillemets qui finalement accepte de
rentrer dans l'orient je regarde
l'angleterre regarde l'homme était un
regard donc l'angleterre n'est pas
encore rentré dans cette alliance nous
fallait un voile hier 15 pays on voit
bien en tout cas elvire fabry que la
l'économie tu es tout de même toujours
une question importante
oui on peut et on est on peut pas
l'exclure parce que pour revenir sur les
questions de défense
l'alliance en matière de défense que si
on reprend la corde début février on
voit bien qu'il ya un engagement sur une
coopération de long terme en matière de
défense russie aussi chine maintenant là
encore une fois la matérialisation de
cette alliance à court terme elle devra
se faire sous le manteau mais les enjeux
économiques la préval dominent très
nettement général jean vincent brisset
puisqu'on ne parle plus de caen si je
comprends bien peut-être que vous avez
un avis différent est ce que la chine
pourrait devenir une sorte de médiateur
possible dans le conflit craignant
alors on a parlé d'un but la chine comme
un médiateur j'ai beaucoup de mal à
l'imaginer dans ce rôle parce qu'elle
est quand même elle a ses intérêts sont
beaucoup plus pour le moment intérêts
idéologiques intérêts pratiques sont
beaucoup plus du côté
du côté de la russie ses intérêts
économiques seraient du côté de
l'occident
et l'ukraine importe peu au milieu de
cette affaire et je ne pense pas que la
chine ne arriverait à se sentir pour
s'établir à faire croire qu'elle est
qu'elle est concerné directement par une
médiation qui lui apporterait sur nous
pas grand chose pour vous êtes d'accord
jean françois di meglio vous nous parler
de cette médiation il ya un petit moment
de répit médiation l'année puis
médiation ça veut dire une capacité
d'engagement très forte
l'une des choses me semble-t-il qui
suscite l'admiration ou en tout cas
l'envi chez les dirigeants chinois
vis-à-vis de la russie c'est leur grande
expérience de la diplomatie
internationale la chine est entrée dans
le jeu international à petits pas bien
sûr elle était présente à 1955 avec les
pays non alignés c'était un début de
diplomatie bien sûr il ya eu l'époque
jean ping mais l'expérience diplomatique
y compris du corps diplomatique chinois
n'a rien à voir si vous vous arrêtez
avec l'expérience diplomatique des
russes qui ont une longue tradition qui
ne remonte pas simplement l'union
soviétique mais qui va beaucoup plus
loin la russie a une tradition de parler
à ses adducteurs la chine
malheureusement n'a pas cette tradition
est là de très très bonnes écoles de
diplomate et là de très très bon
théoricien des relations internationales
nous les rencontrons ils sont
impressionnants mais de là à passer à
l'acte la diplomatie c'est un métier et
ce métier n'est pas tellement pratique
pourquoi est ce qu'on parle beaucoup de
cette médiation possible du côté chinois
on rêve c'est un fait
mais regardez la politique des loups
combattants vous avez bien vu comment
ils se sont comportés les diplomates
chinois à l'étranger qui nous ont
abreuvé d'injures chaque fois qu'il le
pouvait face et non c'est une erreur
totale d'imaginer que la chine se
servirait de médiateur elle n'a aucun
intérêt à le faire et elle ne le fera
pas alors justement la dernière question
qu'on pourrait se poser dans ce débat
tout de même c'est est ce que finalement
ce conflit entraîne une sorte de nouvel
ordre mondial qui serait plus favorable
justement aux intérêts chinois en
l'occurrence jean françois di meglio
parce que il ya effectivement selon
franchement entre la chine et la russie
qui est de faire en sorte qu'il n'y ait
plus de suprématie américaine dans cet
ordre mondial est ce que il y aura un
basculement qui sera plus justement du
côté chinois avoirs russes à l'issue de
crack le 24 février février 2022 nous
reste une date extrêmement importante
dans l'histoire ce que vous décrivez je
dirais que c'est presque un scénario
médian ce n'est pas le scénario extrême
c'est à dire que ça n'est pas sérieux de
conflit mais aujourd'hui on ne peut même
pas exclure un basculement dans une zone
beaucoup plus conflictuel de cet
affrontement donc une zone c'est à dire
vous en asie pacifique
on aurait un effet domino ailleurs que
le bronze est le bon scénario européen
sûr c'est que un médiateur surgissent de
quelque part et fasse comprendre
qu'effectivement il peut se passer
quelque chose d'autre en scénario c'est
peut-être qu'un gouvernement ukrainien
en exil refasse ce que la france libre a
fait et peut-être un jour redonne une
chance à une ukraine voir une russie
démocratique mais il ya aussi de mauvais
scénario de bavures de débordements et
de
effectivement qui concerne les pays
baltes ou d'autres pays et donc là on
est dans un autre scénario que le
scénario actuel et la chine alors quelle
serait sa position dans ce cas c'est
effectivement bien de l'embrasement je
ne sais pas je ne savais pas du tout non
il n'y aura peut-être pas intérêt
non mais ce qui est important maintenant
ses new skies et c'est ça qui compte
maintenant il faut que les démocraties
se réveille et qu'elle dise qui elles
vont se battre pour leur rhume un
qu'elles vont souffrir mais qu'elles
vont y aller alors on veut éviter la
troisième guerre mondiale c'est normal
personne n'a envie d'engager ça mais
tout le reste il faut faire il faut et
il faut engager nos populations à
souffrir le diesel le prix du désert va
augmenter et c'est le prix du pain va
augmenter mais on peut pas rester
passifs à regarder les ukrainiens se
faire bombarder et penser que c'est
normal
donc là il ya déjà une union de toute
l'union européenne
une alliance avec les etats unis etc il
faut il faut montrer que nos valeurs ont
un sens et que la démocratie sert à
quelque chose elle lui fabrique
d'ailleurs les sanctions pour aller plus
loin du côté de bruxelles oui ben on a
vu que de la stratégie européenne comme
la stratégie américaine et d'autres
partenaires a été d'une montée en gamme
progressive il faut en garde et ça peut
s'étendre moi je veux juste revenir sur
un point à propos d' ordre mondial il
faut il faut voir aussi ce que ça peut
donner au niveau des institutions
internationales parce que on vois déjà
qui a quand même beaucoup de choses qui
sont en train de bouger la russie a été
suspendu des bénéfices qu'elle pouvait
tirer de la banque du soutien financier
banque mondiale fmi les niveaux de l'om
s'est également l'organisation mondiale
du commerce conseil de l'europe me
semble-t-il aussi oui et là on voit que
ce sont sa va faire jouer les lignes au
sein d'organisations
qui sont elles mêmes souvent henry en
cours de réflexion de réformes avec des
équilibres à des nouveaux équilibres à
trouver entre les vieilles puissances
industrielles et les nouveaux pays
émergents
donc ça serait logique de blocs qui
reprendrait le dessus il ya déjà des il
ya déjà dans les débats des questions
qui se posent un petit peu sur la
recréation de noyau dur au niveau
international avec des institutions un
peu parallèle ou pas alors ça va un
petit peu trop vite à ce stade mais il
ya déjà des questions qui se posent et
là encore on reviendra sur le
positionnement de la chine alors
justement mais quel serait le rôle des
etats-unis dans ces différentes
institutions y aurait une opposition
entre les etats-unis et la chine on
reviendrait finalement à cette
opposition dont on parle bien avant dont
on parlait bien avant le conflit
ukrainien l'opposition elle est déjà
bien réelle et on le voit à l'om c'est
les états unis sont quand même
maintenant se sont mis sur le strapontin
alors que la chine au contraire elle
affirme qu'elle respecte toutes les
règles de l'om s'est donc il y à il ya
il ya déjà une confrontation de fait qui
est qui est réel génération de passe
quelque chose qu'il faut pas oublier
quand même hein c'est la situation de
l'onu parce que la chine est dans l'onu
bien sûr mais là de sécurité au conseil
de sécurité en plus mais elle a acheté
énormément de clients il faut bien les
appeler clients c'est-à-dire il ya plein
de pays d'afrique enfin des
gouvernements d'afrique qui sont plus ou
moins rémunérés par les chinois pour
voter donc maintenant on est déjà en
minorité parce que il ya le pakistan et
yahia moitié des pays d'afrique lorsque
les dirigeants africains sont arrivés à
pékin pour les jo puisque les rangs
étaient un peu vide nous on n'y est pas
allé donc il fallait remplir ils ont
tous touché chacun plus de cent mille
dollars pour simplement parce qu'ils
sont venus quand on joue quand je dis
qu'ils sont achetés ils sont achetés ça
les chinois ils l'ont ils s'en sont même
pas caché donc
avec ce système ils ont ce système là et
ils ont créé toutes sortes de services
parallèles par exemple il ya la banque
mondiale mais ils ont créé les toutes
les banques d'investissement des routes
de la soie donc il ya un parallélisme
interpol ils ont proposé de créer des
services de sécurité justement sur les
routes de la soie etc etc un peu partout
ils ont créé des alternatifs alors un
jour le basculement risque de se
produire mais par notre naïveté notre
innocent qu'un basculement vers quoi
c'est la question parce que lorsque les
pays africains verront que finalement la
chine ne les soutient pas plus que ça
est-ce qu'ils vont changer leur vote
c'est là que ce qui compte c'est de
parler vérité dire la vérité et éclairer
les populations général jean vincent
brisset est-ce que effectivement il y
aura une sorte de nouvel ordre mondial
en conséquence de la guerre en ukraine
alors il y aura certainement des
changements dans le mondial mais on le
sera encore un petit peu ce qui s'est
vraiment passé un kot la capitale de
structure ni n est ce qu ont abouti à
une partition de l'ukraine c'est alors
un peu quand on voit les développements
des forces russes en ukraine on voit
très bien qu'ils essaient de prendre
entièrement tout ce qui est à l'est du
mièvre et l'ouest et ouest d'hier ça
pourrait elle faire l'objet d'un retrait
d'une négociation mais à l'heure
actuelle ce qu'ils risquent de changer
surtout ça fait de conception de la
diplomatie parce que il faut pas oublier
que depuis maintenant pas mal d'années
depuis maiden
poutine
demande
exige essaie d'obtenir à la fois ce qui
a été un prétexte la libération à
l'autonomie des provinces une ambassade
et province autoproclamée indépendante
des tons basse et la garantie de non
adhésion de l'ukraine à l'automne
si le conflit se termine par ce que
poutine obtiennent à la fois la nonne
adhésion à l'otan est cette autonomie
qui était prévu par les accords de minsk
qui a pas été respecté ça voudra dire
que il regagnait par la force à ce qu'il
n'a pas réussi à obtenir par la
diplomatie avant le 21 février et ça
voudrait dire sans doute comment
combiner avec la totale inexistence de
l'onu dans cette prise à la mort d'une
certaine diplomatie celle qu'on a c'est
le coma et sait mettre en place avec les
sd est la première guerre mondiale et
avait que l'onu après la deuxième guerre
mondiale
c'est un peu la mort définitive de l'onu
vous êtes d'accord jean françois di
meglio
mais ce que disait de vire est
extrêmement intéressant pour parler l'om
c'est sinon de l'onu le fait
qu'effectivement les américains qui
incarne cet ordre libéral endossé par
l'om c'est soit sur un strapontin
effectivement se met en retrait ça
laisse effectivement la place
donc l'onu pourra ne pas changer de nom
mais on pourrait avoir d'autres
principes qui présiderait et encore une
fois ce que ce que ce que ce que dit
marie doit être répétée et affirmer
notre style c'est à dire c'est à nous à
nous de prendre nos responsabilités et
de savoir exactement ce que nous voulons
wiseman il faut savoir ce que nous
voulons vous servir en fait si on
revient justement au sujet de départ qui
en fait cette alliance entre la chine et
la russie contre l'occident il ya tout
de même effectivement on l'a dit ce
qu'on voulait entre les démocraties et
se bloquent mais j'ai dit ce qu'on
voulait prêt à déclencher à laquelle on
a instauré un multilatéralisme un
multilatéralisme
effectivement avec des avec des leaders
du monde occidentaux ils montrent
oxydantes avancer c'est quelque chose
comme ça que l'on veut on peut l'adapter
la chine peut voir sa place dans cet
ordre là personne n'a dit que la chine
n'aurait pas sa place c'est ça qu'on
veut c'est assez simple c'est assez
simple oui mais quand joe biden a
proposé de faire une réunion avec des
gens qui partageaient les mêmes valeurs
j'ai trouvé que c'était assez audacieux
parce que c'est pas politiquement
correct ça mais ils essayent de recréer
l'alliance des véritable démocratie
n'arrive pas vraiment il n'y avait pas
vraiment mais c'est ça qui est majeur
moyen les intérêts économiques dont
parlait elvire fabry
oui mais il faut voir à quoi on s'expose
c'était le sommet des démocraties et je
pense qu'il aurait dû inviter justement
les chinois parce que les chinois nous
disent que la démocratie chez eux c'est
glee live où il était invité me sens oui
s'il admet avoir avoir de chine au
sommet des démocraties les amateurs
pourront entendre ce qu était la
définition de démocratie pour le cid et
nous aurions vu effectivement qu'il y
avait une différence entre les
interprétations de la démocratie
conforme ceux déjà acquis à une
différence entre le régime chinois et
travailler pour la chine c'est
effectivement donner à manger à tout le
monde et ses assesseuses sortir sa
population de la pauvreté je crois qu'il
faut effectivement l'entendre il ne faut
pas le rejeter mais il faut aussi
expliquer que c'est pas le tout le file
oméga de la démocratie qu'est aussi
d'autres choses qui viennent avec non
non à léo sur hbo a quand même écrit la
philosophie du porc un an nourrir les
porcs et on les abritent mais les
humains c'est pas ça
mais c'est pas ça merci beaucoup en tout
cas d'avoir été avec nous marie holzman
jean françois di meglio merci elvire
fabry merci à vous général jean vincent
brisset merci à vous tous devoir civique
reste avec 924